okay so this video we're going to look
at the process of ecological secession
and discuss primary versus secondary
secession so let's get started you know
what is secession even mean let's use
another example first if I were to ask
you what president seceded Jimmy Carter
I hope you would know oh that was Ronald
Reagan who seceded Ronald Reagan that
was George Bush senior who seceded
George Bush Senior that was Bill Clinton
who seceded Bill Clinton that was George
Bush jr. who seceded George Bush that
was Brock Obama and who's acceded Barack
Obama we have Donald Trump
so in this examples secede means to
follow and that's what secession means
we're gonna keep that in mind as we go
through this so let's look at primary
secession you know the definition is
pretty straightforward it's the
establishment and the development of an
ecosystem in an uninhabited area so
here's an uninhabited area and what
happens is this ecosystem is going to go
through a series of changes so small
life begins to grow and then a little
bigger and then a little bigger and then
a little bigger how does this gradual
series of changes occur within this
environment
that's what this video is going to
discuss so when it comes as a primary
secession there's really two modes in
which this is gonna occur and and that's
through volcanic lava creating new land
you know here's an area let's add some
plants and let's add some animals and
let's say in the background of this area
there's an erupting volcano and as as
time goes by it this volcanoes erupting
the lava is flowing into the ocean and
it starts to pile up and pile up and
pile up and pile up you know eventually
this lava is gonna cool and Harden and
when this lava cools and harden it
hardens into new barren land
now this land this rock it's not gonna
stay barren forever it's gonna go
through primary secession and we'll talk
about that in just a few moments you
know here we have a picture of some lava
flowing into a body of water probably
into an ocean and eventually this lava
is gonna cool and solidify and
eventually can walk around on it and
eventually this will turn into you know
a wilderness ecosystem well another way
in which primary secession can proceed
is through glacial retreat you know here
we have our frozen a frozen glacier and
as the seasons change and the
temperatures of this planet are warming
up this glacier is retreating and when
it does it exposes new barren land now
the land is barren currently but after
primary secession we're gonna see a
wilderness ecosystem begin to grow and
live in this area you know here's a
great picture from 1909 taken from a
glacier in Alaska watch how the picture
changes it almost a hundred years later
notice how the glacier has retreated and
the barren rock is actually very full of
green vegetation in this picture so how
does this process occur well let's start
with X to the volcano example let's use
a here some lava flowing into an ocean
and eventually this lava is gonna cool
and hardened into rock or land and here
again we have the the rock is hardened
the lava has hardened and it's barren a
looks like a vast barren wasteland right
now so the first organisms to inhabit
this barren rocky world are what are
called pioneer species now if I ask you
what's a pioneer well here here's an
example Lewis and Clark were European
pioneers that first explored westward
across America all the way to the west
coast of California Alexander Fleming
Sir Alexander Fleming was a pioneer in
medicine he helped to develop the first
ever antibiotic called penicillin
and Elvis Presley was a pioneer in rock
and roll these three examples nicely
show what a pioneer is they're one of
the First's to come along and in this
case pioneer species are the first
organisms to inhabit this new land now
I'm not talking about the people in the
picture I'm talking about other
organisms that encounter this at this
area and begin to grow so what organisms
are even capable of growing in a vast
wasteland well Moss would be one here's
a picture of moss growing on Iraq and
lichen is another lichen as a mixture of
of a bacteria algae like bacteria and a
fungus living together mutually but
these two organisms are able to grow and
live on on barren rock and so moss and
lichen are commonly called pioneer
species because they can live in this
environment where other organisms just
can't and so if we look at this rocky
land here how do the moss and lichen get
into this new this new newly created
piece of land here well through the wind
as a wind and rain and weather will
carry the reproductive cells of moss and
lichen their spores and they're carried
through the wind and eventually there
and carried the rain and eventually they
settle in this area here and then they
begin to grow and so lichen and moss
actually come in these real pretty
colors here's some white and reds here's
some kind of yellowish greens here's
some kind of lime green colors so I'm
gonna illustrate moss and lichen in my
animation here with the gold the red the
green squiggly lines those are moss and
lichen that are growing on this barren
wasteland of a of an environment right
here well as time passes moss live die
live reproduce and die
lichens live reproduce and die and
they're dead matter accumulates as
two pieces of crumbling rocks so over
time this accumulation of dead organic
matter from moss and lichen and the
crumbling of rocks forms a real thin
layer of soil not enough soil for big
old trees and and you know redwood trees
and oak trees and things like that to
grow but enough to stimulate the
production of even more moss and lichen
and so what was once a vast rocky barren
wasteland is slowly starting to show
signs of life and so as the process
continues eventually seeds are gonna
enter this area and begin to grow now
how do the seeds get there well one way
is through birds birds will eat fruit
and then poop out the seeds and as they
fly overhead and they poop out the seeds
the seeds land in this new area another
way many seeds are transported via wind
many seeds have little like blades on
them that help them catch the wind and
glide and travel vast distances and so
here comes some seeds that just entered
and now that the seeds have entered this
new land the seeds begin to grow the
seeds begin to grow into small flowers
and small shrubs and over time as
flowers you know lose their petals as
these shrubs shed their leaves all of
this accumulates on the ground and adds
even more thickness to the soil and so
as time passes they know the flowers
reproduce the shrubs reproduce again
there's another flower reproducing and
as time passes the layer of soil becomes
even thicker because you have years and
years and years now of growth just
accumulating through flower petals and
decaying leaves and moss and lichen
decaying rocks crumbling and adding to
the soil and so with this new
environment come animals animals of
course are always looking for new
habitats new areas to hide from their
predators and new food sources and
wherever there's herbivores you better
believe carnivores are going to follow
insert to prey so what
once a rocky barren wasteland is slowly
developing into a thriving ecosystem and
as even more time passes small trees
begin to take root again how do the
seeds get there well if you wind and
through bird droppings and so small
trees over the over the decades begin to
grow in this area and that adds even
more thickness to the soil because again
now you got another few decades of moss
and lichen accumulating in another few
decades of flower petals and leaves and
rocks crumbling and now you have mouse
droppings and snake droppings and all of
this all this adds to the thickness of
the soil which allows even taller plant
life to begin to grow and of course
where there's more vegetation and more
plants there's more habitats for animals
so birds might now migrate into this
area and insects might take advantage
and let's say a little squirrel migrates
and and runs up into this tree here and
eventually we reach the climax community
notice how the soil became even thicker
because as the decades go by a more and
more organic matter accumulates more and
more soil accumulates on the ground and
larger trees begin to take root how did
the seeds get there when carries them
rain carries the seeds bird droppings
carry the seeds and over time you get
these massive huge tall canopy trees and
sadly these tall canopy trees will often
out-compete and overcrowd some of the
original vegetation that was there and
now that these tall canopy trees are
blocking all the sunlight you start to
see some of the death of the
ground-level vegetation and this is
characteristic of a climax community and
of course this bigger trees and bigger
habitats allows even more animals to
inhabit this forest so bunnies and
rabbits come along and and owls flying
in and so now we have a thriving
ecosystem where let's say maybe a
hundred hundred and fifty two hundred
years ago this might have been just
barren a barren wasteland barren rock
so that was primary secession now let's
start with secondary secession so you
know it's a change that takes place
after a disturbance occurs in an
established ecosystem so here's our
climax community that we just finished
talking about and let's say a
disturbance happens maybe it's a forest
fire or flood some type of disturbance
and in this case we're going to show you
that the secondary secession process is
just much faster because the soil still
exists so in this case here we have a
lightning strike and it starts a fire
and oh man we have this wildfire and of
course birds are gonna fly away and
whatever animals can can run away and
eventually you know this fire is gonna
spread and eventually could be the death
to some of these trees here and
eventually as time goes by as fuel runs
low eventually the fire goes out well
once the fire is out
notice how the soil still remains so
secession is going to secondary
secession is going to reestablish this
ecosystem so as time passes you know
grasses begin to grow again seeds drift
there and drift in the wind and through
rain and and through the droppings of
animals and eventually small shrubs and
bushes and flowers will begin to regrow
and eventually trees will regrow and
wildlife will come back and and reoccupy
this area this is secondary secession
and eventually we come back to our
climax community where because the trees
are so tall and dense they actually
might crowd out some of the smaller
vegetation the ecosystem has
reestablished itself after this
disturbance that secondary secession you
know here's a real nice series of
pictures that were taken that nicely
show secondary secession after a forest
fire so this picture right here was
taken one year after this fire was
extinguished well now here's the same
area two years after the fire here's the
area three years after
four years after notice how the
ecosystem is reestablishing itself
here's five years after six years after
seven years after eight years after you
see as time passes more and more and
more growth accumulates and as time
continues this environment will be
reestablished in that secondary
secession you know another example of
secondary secession is like when a tree
falls when a tree falls in a in a forest
that leaves a big gap in the canopy and
that gap is a resource for other trees
because if if you can grow and occupy
that gap you have access to sunlight and
so as a tree falls through the act of
secondary succession other organisms
will re occupy and and fill in that gap
and it might be a different species of
tree it could be the same species of
tree but eventually that gap gets filled
in and the ecosystem is reestablished
you know there's some real interesting
examples of secondary succession you
know here's a picture of the town
prypiat in Ukraine which is the location
of the Chernobyl nuclear power plant
which experienced a nuclear meltdown in
1986 so this city has been abandoned
since 1986 and you can see in the plaza
here plants and vegetation are beginning
to grow plants are over growing and in
all areas and the the the ecosystem was
beginning to regrow and reestablish
itself after years of human neglect you
know speaking of neglect here we have
urban decay and here's a picture in New
Jersey again you can see in areas that
aren't well-maintained
you can see the sidewalk is crumbling
and plants are beginning to break
through and and life and the life in
this once ecosystem is trying to
re-establish itself you know if I'm not
careful I can get sucked into Wikipedia
and read about these all day and
abandoned farms and ghost town you know
here's a farm that was abandoned you
know at one time this farm Woods was you
know cultivated and had crops
but after being abandoned and neglected
the ecosystem began to re-establish
itself in this area here so there you
have it primary versus secondary
secession if you're in my biology class
pause the video and you know try these
and let me check your answers and see
how you did and I hope you enjoy the
video thanks for watching